Kimberly is in Lexington Kentucky I
Kimberly how are you I'm good days how
are you doing
better than I deserve what's up um well
my husband and I are not in agreement on
how has that in him handled the profit
from their business okay how do they how
do they handle the profits in the
business and what do you disagree with
well they've been buying junk cars and
they bought a house and the problem is
there's no money coming home she's the
family you know so if we've been
struggling they had this going on for a
couple years now
and it's really put a bond on our
relationship do you work outside the
home I do
what do you may have what um well I just
started picking up some extra work I'm
not really sure how much what do you
make roughly roughly forty to forty-five
anyway and how much is he bringing home
from this business well last year he
technically made $5,000 is that what he
brought home I don't really see I mean I
don't have an estimate of what healing
found because we separated all of our
bills in February and he's responsible
for his half which it is hurting me now
because he's not paying his half of the
house payment you know he went several
months without doing that so it's been a
problem but according to him he's paying
all these bills and there's no money to
pay all the bills you know he's not
paying all these bills we mean he's
paying girls at the office yeah well
when he's buying these cars and they're
paying the rent on are the mortgage on
the house that they bought and so he's
bought he's paying for things but I
tried to explain to him you know the
family he's putting the family at the
bottom of the barrel you know we get
scratched yeah
you know whenever he can I mean I'm his
responses response to that is what
oh it makes you mad he feels like I'm
you know being mean because I'm playing
this but it's true I mean he does he
does he disagree with you he thinks
she's providing for the family um he
knows that he's behind he does know that
I mean I bought the groceries with my
sticker shops and you know if we go out
to eat and I you know pick up secret
shops to do that so that we're not
really spending a lot of money on things
like that but we have a huge day care
bill because we have two small children
in daycare and he wants me to stay at
home and keep the kids so that we not
the daycare bill out well we also knock
out the insurance that I'm getting some
work and you know the money that I'm
making how are you guys how are you guys
in a church yeah okay you need to call
your pastor well he's involved he's been
involved but you know we need you need
marriage counseling because let me tell
you from 30 years you're not you're not
done you need a marriage counselor who
will tell you the truth and we'll tell
him the truth because I can tell you
from 30 years of doing financial
counseling that you're about to get a
divorce when we are this is about over
you are they listening to you for the
last two and a half minutes you're about
done and and everybody listening knows
that you're about done and so and you
know who doesn't know you're about done
Bubba he don't know you're about done
he's still he's still living in la-la
land and he still he did not leave his
parents and cleave to his wife that's
one of the most difficult things in
family business is my son-in-law works
here and he Rachel's husband works on my
team and Rachel works on my team and I
have to be very very careful to allow
them to be adults and have their own
couple identity apart from being my kid
and apart from working on my team
because otherwise I'm basically
neutering my son-in-law
and that's a bad plan so you really have
to work at that and his dad and him are
relational morons they have no clue of
what I'm talking
about right here and they're just
they're just good they're just good old
boys out there buying crap they are
that's and he hadn't gotta buy and got a
bad arm
I got a bad heart he's just dumber than
a rock over him and how he relates to
his wife yeah that's what's going on he
doesn't have a bad heart he just he's
they're just being ignorant and
somebody's going to have to love him
enough to look at him and tell him that
and that's I hope your pastors got a
spine well he has told him over and over
to stop buying these cars and and
finally he got to a point where he was
negative on his bank account for so long
yeah they all know I think I think you
need to sit down with somebody maybe in
addition to your pastor that's a
professional marriage counselor or the
Christian perspective because you need
to formalize your ask and your demand
because what's going to happen is is
you're just going to blow up and you're
going to the switch is going to flip and
nobody's going to reel you back in
you're going to be so done
and it's before that happens you need to
say baby by this date we have to change
this or I'm done you're gonna have to
give him that ultimatum but you need
guidance to do that that's not a radio
host this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
you guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
than
to tell them I said that I'm kidding I'm
kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
check out how to do a monthly budget
it's one of the best videos out there
you